well guys it is a lovely full moon
halloween
night shall we go for a little hike yeah
all right let's go
let's go for a hike in the woods
oh it's getting a little foggy tonight
hey guys should we go and wander deeper
into the woods without a trail
stay close we don't want you to
disappear like all those other kids that
disappeared this week
hey guys i heard a strange noise should
we go and investigate
oh this fog is getting thick
becca have you seen tommy tommy
tommy ah let's go deeper into the woods
to look for tommy
[Music]
do you know where nathan is no we lost
nathan
yeah nathan's gone too darn it all right
let's go deeper into the woods and see
if we can't find him okay
okay
oh this fog is thick
i don't see nathan or tommy anywhere do
you
hey becca didn't you have jacob
oh crap we lost jacob too
becca we've lost tommy nathan and jacob
do you know what this means
[Music]
all right guys we get the hammock set up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well guys do you like that hammock ted
it's the halloween season and it's time
for a super scary
halloween camp out and we're bringing
the whole family becca and jacob will be
joining
me tommy and nate and uh we're gonna do
some
halloween campfire cooking
[Applause]
that's
gonna try not to crazy the food
it's like gutting the fish now tommy
hold on to the guts and seeds we're
gonna cook those up here okay
look who's here mama
[Music]
[Music]
get a whiff of that yes please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey yeah
is
[Music]
oh what you got there oh that's a big
one
you need some help nope you got it all
right
i'm messing with the food i look up and
all of a sudden this
like 10 pound pumpkin is just barreling
through the woods
so uh we're gonna go check out the
carnage
okay here watch out watch out
oh it's pumpkin seeds they're everywhere
okay don't careful careful careful we
can still we can still eat the pumpkin
seeds
oh yeah who's excited to climb back up
this ravine with a pumpkin
don't don't get back off oh yeah that's
a copperhead
but see how he's light brown dark brown
with light brown inside
yeah that's a copperhead i was like what
was he did i then i saw him
see the tip of the tail now it's yellow
baby copperhead's always got that
i forgot about copperhead we don't see
them that often do we
yeah there's a whole bunch of seeds
they're all kind of on one side well the
pork and pumpkin has been stewing for
about four hours so we're gonna lift up
the bin and see what it looks like
[Music]
does not look good that's okay we don't
eat the outside
we eat the inside
all right look we got this nice loaf of
bread here
that is perfect first dibs go to mama
oh my goodness it smelled beautiful
it smells so good yeah you do want some
pretty good it's very good
[Music]
mama did that stu hit the spot yeah
so i think mama's gonna do a little
painting and i'm gonna try to cook up
those pumpkin seeds and then we've got
some fun stuff planned for dessert later
tonight
i think we're gonna make popcorn balls
and i've got some pumpkin pie
stashed around here somewhere and uh
then we're gonna hang out in our hammock
tent
and uh tell some spooky ghost stories
i'm trying to be bold and messy what do
you think i think you're being very bold
and it looks great
[Music]
you guys want some fried pumpkin seeds
just like pumpkin seeds so delicious oh
you dropped them inside you gotta eat
that
they look horrible but they actually
taste good is that right
everything tastes better over a campfire
and takes 10 times more work
[Music]
uh
[Music]
how about you both work together
i dubbed the leftover popcorn kernels in
the fire and predictably now
we've got popcorn and flaming popcorn
going everywhere are you guys carving
that pumpkin
yeah now you can now you can cut its top
off
what the [ __ ]
it's flat as a pancake
just put some water on my hands and take
the popcorn mush it into a ball and
there we go
popcorn balls who wants one there you go
mama you want one it's basically just
rice krispie treats with popcorn instead
of rice krispies
are you guys having a good halloween
camp out
cuz it's getting so foggy it's getting
hard to see why don't you guys get in
the tent and we can tell spooky's story
here comes dad do you want me to tell
you a story
a story about a brave man named kevin
bacon and how he was trying to escape
from worms that would
would grab people from under the ground
you sleep okay nathan
you okay jacob
[Music]
tommy's in here somewhere
he's still sleeping all right
ready to go see mama yeah
well guys this is one of those campouts
where we got to cut it short and get
running home as quickly as we can
we hope you guys enjoyed it we hope you
had a good time and if you want to see
more camping videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel we
got an entire playlist i'll put a link
in the description
we also have a whole bunch of campfire
cooking videos
including a whole bunch of awesome
recipes and i'll put a link in the
description
to that video as well but thanks for
watching and don't forget to click
subscribe
i'll see you guys next saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching